Film Courage: How is it possible that you read
a screenplay what 50 times before you shoot it?
Pete Chatmon, Director/Podcaster/Author: Yeah
so when I get my perspective on directing is
I'm trying to be the authority on the material
and most of the things that I do that are in
the feature or short space I've written or I've
been part I've been a part of that process from
the beginning. I've given notes from the
beginning. I'm aware of all of the kind of
mental gymnastics that are behind those 110 pages
or those 120 pages. When I get a script for TV
because I haven't been privy or had
the privilege of seeing that process.
I'm trying to get a very thorough understanding of
what's on the page so I can begin to deconstruct
what I think that process may have been. That
means I'm reading the script as many times as I
can in as many different environments as I can.
I'm reading the script as different crew people
(this is just my personal take). I like to read
it as the cinematographer. I like to read it as
the wardrobe costume designer. I like to read
it as the production designer because then and
I read it as a director last because I feel like
all of those things help me get into the mind of
the people I'm collaborating with but like B
I get an understanding of what I have at my
disposal as the director so I could read a scene
in on the third reading maybe I'm like oh what
now I'm thinking about it as the actor because
I've done all the other thinking and I'm like
oh what if the actor wants to sit down in this
scene well I'd love for them to have a chaise
lounge versus like a chair so now that third
reading revealed a furniture selection what
or if I'm reading at home versus reading
at a cafe when the world was open like that
sometimes just being around a bunch of
people changes what I'm digesting so
it's important for me to do that I also make
a spreadsheet where I take all the story lines
and this comes from another book on directing
I'll take all the story lines and put them in
a different column so I can have a top-down look
at the architecture of the entire episode and it
also doubles as a brief refresher for me on
set should I need it or if an actor is like
well where was I in the last scene and I'll be
like oh well that was what doing Scene 40 now
but in scene 22 you did XYZ and then they can
be like okay great I know where I'm coming from
so again being as thorough as possible is the is
the is the goal interesting so you would digest
a script differently in let's say a busy coffee
shop here in Los Angeles than you would let's say
in a library yeah and I think it's just it's kind
of hard to explain with any value that's not like
it just feels different but like you
you might be paying more attention
in one of those settings that you had in
another or maybe you heard something in
the background that triggered a subconscious
thought about something you're experiencing
here I don't know yeah I can't put
it I can't put like a thumb on it or
point to what it is exactly but I do
think I know for sure like I've it's been
on subsequent readings where something is
revealed and so I'm trying to really give
myself as many opportunities to find out
find those Revelations before I'm on set
and as the Director lasts you where the director's
hat reading it last that's interesting because I
feel like I can't I have to I have to I'm I can
only direct something that's been figured out
like otherwise like I'm I'm putting
camera in random places that are
not driven by actor or like some other
level of like thematic thought that is
Tethered to story because I could I could very
easily be like oh yeah I put the camera here I'll
do that that we will swoop around but then like
as you read it you're like I'm going to treat
that storyline like this actually and I have
to I have to settle into it a little bit more
do you ask the screenwriter for story a b story C
story or how many story lines are in the episode
I when I get the script I I extract them myself
I try and identify them as oh the a story is
this character is having a crisis of confidence
about something at home and then the B story is
this thing at work and then the C story is one
of the kids is going through XYZ and then the
d-store and I'm sure sometimes I'm probably maybe
adding a storyline because I might I might really
carve them out to be distinctive but maybe in
their mind something is a similar storyline
but yeah just go in and carve it out and when I
I have time I'll try and give each scene a name
now I have less and less at that time now but I
try and give each scene a name so I'm like as I
step into directing it's like this is so-and-so's
retribution or whatever it might be so I can kind
of have a guiding principle for how I'm talking
about the scene to the actors or the crew how I
want to shoot it and just have a something that's
helping me make have a point of view because at
the end of the day I think I'm there to apply
in a point of view and a point to apply a point
of view from which to shoot and direct the scene
right because we were talking about inventing Anna
before we when we were setting up and so I guess
you could say well we're learning about this
journalist and she's there and she doesn't want to
do another me too story she wants to do something
else and she's in war with her editor and she's
just fascinated by this the story of this woman
and she's having a crisis at home I guess
I don't know if she's going to have a baby
or she's trying to or something and she's not
even sure she wants to right and then she just
becomes obsessed with this woman almost as a way
to avoid her own life really in a lot of ways so
yeah that's those are basically the three stories
and I'm sure there's other parts to it but yeah
that's right you had me thinking of that just
because yeah in different episodes there were
probably other characters where I was like and
this is the D story and this is the E because
some other supporting character was important
to because there's always it's always this point
Counterpoint to whatever the theme is it's like
here is this idea represented at its best via
this character and here's this idea represented
at its perhaps worst through this character and
the cocktail of the entire episode hopefully
says and here's what we think about that
right and maybe that's when she meets the
other people that knew Anna right okay that
makes sense yeah now I see what you're talking
about how do you figure out how many story lines
are in an episode yeah it's just carving them
out as I so like functionally like as I read
the script and this is well this is probably
into second or third reading like the first
one is I try and let that be uninterrupted and
purely as a reader so I can kind of just say oh
okay here's the story that it's is being told I
don't want to start saying like oh that's funny
oh that's witty or making notes on I think
that's a high angle shot like I just want to
read it uninterrupted but second or third episode
I'll go through and when making that spreadsheet
first scene is usually what the episode's about
right so okay boom I'll take that second scene
I'll just go scene by scene until all of the until
I and and as and as a new storyline is introduced
I'll give it a new heading more often than not
I don't think you're going to get out of act one
without having been introduced to all of them
and so and it's in television and some of the
some of the shows will literally tell you this
is the cold open this is act one end of act one
Others May do dip to Black which is basically
the same thing and so like in in that
act one or in that first area of scenes before
it dips to Black that's probably going to be all
of the story lines that are at play because
it moves so quickly that you're not likely
to have a new storyline introduced in Act 2.
so you haven't like an Excel document already
sort of like plugged in and then you just for
each new project you just plug okay interesting
and so you do that fairly soon after you've read
the script a few times I'll do that fairly soon
like I mentioned it's useful for being on set
but it's also useful in prep because in prep
I'm out on I'm in the van or I'm self-driving and
we're going to all these different locations and
now instead of having to thumb through
the script I can go to my spreadsheet
and say oh yeah okay this is that scene
though and then on a location scout I can
glance really quickly remind myself of why
we're here and what what we need and then
move through the process pretty efficiently okay
and this is going to be different than a shot
list yes much different okay yeah yeah do you do
anything that's more tangible that's not on the
iPad or your laptop no the the driver before
covid I used to have I used to have a script
and I would have the shot list that I would print
out from Hollywood shot designer and that would be
a function of getting the floor plans from that
that I can show you that would be a function
of getting the floor plans from resume
editing yeah that would be a function of
getting the floor plans from the production
designer and then implementing them into
Hollywood shop designer and then
blocking it so as an example
this is a floor plan from a location a club
location in West Adams for a scene from Insecure
and this was three characters walking up to a club
and I'm sorry two characters walking up to a club
Issa and Daniel she's blue he's red they find
a bouncer at the door bouncer one and bouncer
two are our gray folks and then we had another
character I didn't put the name here but that
she knew from high school who walks up and
helps get them into the club and so I've got
I don't necessarily put everything in here but I'm
I at least have the broad Strokes I had this wide
from across the street that tracked with them as
they walked past the line of people thinking that
they would walk up and get in of course they
don't and they get they're met with security
I think this wide from it says why from across
symmetrical tighter for crowd exit that was
something that I got at the end of the night
it was for the end of the sequence but I got it
you shoot all the exteriors at one time and then
I knew I would have I would bring them back on
this Steadicam shot in the green landing and over
the bouncer back to them and then I would have
coverage and then coverage going both ways and so
in the in the pre-covered days I would have these
all printed out and I would have my script printed
out and I would just kind of walk around with
all of these I'd share those with the ad and with
the DP and obviously things change some scenes go
exactly as planned but it's mostly to have a plan
and to be able to have the crew prep towards an
idea because even if the coverage all changes this
is more this is where the actors are going to be
and so but with covid in the beginning there
was a commitment to not to being paperless
to not handing like when when people
were watching their mail like it was
uh no Productions were handing out scripts so
everything became electronic and so another app
that I use scriptation became my go-to and so it's
great because the script's in there now I don't
have to have a script I can update new drafts with
my notes from a prior script and instead of having
that app I showed you Hollywood shop designer
I would just add a page into the script take a
screenshot of the plan and just draw on it in the
script so then everything just became one document
and so that's called shot Lister that's called
Hollywood shot designer shot designer I'm sorry
and so you can kind of just plug in the exact
sort of what that you said Issa Rae was red her
character right and then the the other character
was blue and then gray were the friends and stuff
so you can assign the sort of the yeah there's
a bunch of like icons for characters they have
lights they have different props they have cars
and motorcycles and kind of all the basic things
that would pop up and you can just say and if
you want you can animate the cameras but at a
certain point I I feel like it becomes a little
too much because you'll figure you have to leave
room to figure it out on the day but it's a
great device for prep so people can have an
idea of where the production should be leaning and
so and everybody gets a copy of that well in this
case the DP and ad because they're filtering it
out to the camera department and then the ad is
it's helpful for the ad to be able to manage how
much time will be needed for a particular scene
but actors and backgrounds I might show it
to them if they wanted to but overwhelmingly
comes down to the communication which is the
again like the tough part of the job like
being able to relay what you want being
able to do it in a way where you're not
a dictator and you like you like in my mind
I've got this whole scene figured out because I
I can't show up without having done that now it
doesn't mean I'm right but I've got it all figured
out and I've got to allow the actors and the
cinematographer everybody to have their time to
find it and also feel collaborative
in it and so it's like finding out
finding developing the methods to do that
that's the journey I think of the director.